would you rather have a good hand job  from your grandmother  or a bad hand job from your grandmother  [Laughter]  that's hilarious you [ __ ] you sick  [ __ ]  you're already getting one  you know you're already getting one put  it this way okay I I asked this to my  friends I said you go to prison and the  biggest guy there says you're dead today  or you have protection for your life you  gotta suck my dick once so you have to  are you gonna try to give them a good  [ __ ] or you're not gay so just give  them a [ __ ] one that's a good one  too you know  so it kind of goes down to that and then  my dear friend Colleen said  do you want good production or bad  protection in the prison going with a  good hand job  [Laughter]